c'est l'une des affaires criminelles les
plus médiatisés de ces dernières années
elle s'appelle maëlys elle a 9 ans on
est sans nouvelles d'elle depuis plus de
24 heures maintenant dans la nuit du 26
au 27 août 2010 est une fillette
disparaît lors d'un mariage à pont de
beauvoisin en isère très vite les
recherches s'organisent ça c'est sûr
qu'à eu des recherches compare tout
autour il y avait du monde pour chercher
pour fouiller les mois
[Musique]
notre maison a été visitée la maison des
voisins aussi enfin tout le quartier a
été interrogés sans résultat il n'y a
aucune trace de la petite fille mais
quatre jours après la disparition le 31
août 2010 cette première avancée un
homme est arrêté un homme de 34 ans a
reconnu que la petite fille était monté
dans sa voiture et il a été placé en
détention provisoire et mis en examen
son nom nordahl le landais c'est le
suspect numéro un cet ancien militaire
était présent au mariage au moment des
faits et dans sa voiture les enquêteurs
font une surprenante découverte dans sa
voiture une audi de l'adn de la fillette
a été retrouvée sur un bouton du tableau
de bord ces traces auraient été laissées
le soir du mariage selon nordahl le
landais melli serait monté dans sa
voiture pour voir ses chiens mais cette
version ne convainc ni les enquêteurs ni
les parents de la petite fille nous
laisse à penser tu pourra détenir les
informations importantes et pour et
pouvant nous aider à retrouver notre
fille
doit sûrement le 6 posé beaucoup de
questions à réfléchir depuis sa cellule
autre élément troublant nordahl le
landais à nettoyer sa voiture de fond en
comble lendemain de la disparition pour
la vendre selon lui
mais le suspect continue de nier en bloc
jusqu'au 14 février 2018 ce jour là coup
de théâtre les enquêteurs font une
nouvelle découverte dans le coffre de sa
voiture les gendarmes ont découvert une
tache de sang et les experts de la
gendarmerie ont déterminé c'est tout
récent que ce sens était celui de maylis
la preuve est accablante
normal le landais craque et avoue il a
bien tué la petite maëlys
accidentellement selon lui le corps de
la victime est retrouvée dans le massif
de la chartreuse sur les indications du
suspect dans le camp des a eu un déclic
tout le monde doutait de la réalité de
ce qu il indiqué je viens d'apprendre
que ce qu'il a indiqué étaient exactes
quatre ans plus tard le procès de normal
le landais s'ouvre au palais de justice
de grenoble il va durer trois semaines
c'est le deuxième procès en quelques
mois pour l'ancien militaire en mai 2021
il avait été reconnu coupable et
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour un autre meurtre celui
du caporal arthur noyer
[Musique]